difficile de trouver un créneau
disponibles pour la vaccination dans les
yvelines
en ce moment c'est la conséquence de
l'allocution du président de la
république lundi 12 juillet dernier
emmanuel macron a en effet annoncé le
passage à la vaccination obligatoire
pour l'ensemble des soignants mais aussi
l'extension du pass sanitaires pour
profiter des lieux culturels ou encore
des restaurants dès cet été
comme partout en france les centres de
vaccination y vit noah n'ont pas échappé
à la ruée vers la piqûre dans les
vaccinodromes de mantes-la-jolie et du
centre commercial vélizy 2 tous les
rendez vous sont pris jusqu'à fin
juillet alors que la semaine dernière il
était encore possible de s'y prendre
seulement quelques jours à l'avance au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines transformer en
vaccinodromes même combat depuis lundi
aucun rendez-vous mais disponible avant
la mi-août ce jeudi 15 juillet ce ne
sont pas moins de 2300 personnes qui ont
été vaccinées dans ce centre dont 250
personnes sans rendez vous le vaccine
aux romands enregistrent depuis lundi
entre 350 et 400 injection par heure au
lieu de 300 habituellement cet été s'ils
restent ouverts ce ne sera qu'à mi-temps
de 8 heures à 14 heures cinq jours par
semaine
en revanche l'organisation la sueur elle
va densifier le nombre de vaccinés à
l'heure outre le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines trois autres
centres de vaccination reste aussi
ouvert tout l'été le centre commercial
vélizy 2 saint germain en laye et nantes
la jolie pour les autres centres encore
ouverts comme celui de versailles par
exemple ils fermeront leurs portes pour
la période estivale du 31 juillet au 22
août inclus
excepté ceux de chatou bonnières sur
seine et rambouillet qui se ferment
définitivement leurs portes
si la prise de rendez vous n'est pas
disponible il reste une dernière
solution pour se faire vacciner les
opérations éphémère organisées dans le
département cet été d'abord ce vendredi
16 samedi 17 juillet à la base de
loisirs de verneuil sur seine puis sur
les aires d'autoroute de morainvilliers
les 23 et 24 juillet enfin entre le 30
juillet et le 4 septembre dans lé
quartier des mureaux et du 24 au 26 août
aux centres sociaux de carrières sous
poissy 1 mais t es deux vaccinations
donc dans les yvelines
seul moyen d'obtenir le précieux sésame
le pass and terre pour la rentrée